[Música]
Colombia se prepara para albergar la
Cumbre sobre la situación política en
Venezuela en la que participarán cerca
de 20 países el líder opositor Juan
guaidó viajó a Bogotá pero no estará en
la conferencia el presidente Nicolás
Maduro afirmó que Espera que se levanten
todas las sanciones contra su país
[Música]
taker Carlton uno de los presentadores
estrella de Fox news dejó la cadena
estadounidense su salida se produce una
semana después de que el canal de
noticias pactará un pago por más de 787
millones de dólares condominio en
bautings para evitar un juicio por
difamación
el más reciente censo en Brasil habla de
casi el doble de indígenas en
comparación con las estadísticas
anteriores el conteo preliminar señala
que hay uno coma seis millones de los
cuales 320,000 viven en las áreas
urbanas les traemos la historia desde el
gigante sudamericano
Bienvenidos a las noticias que France 24
le dedica a América yo soy María Clara
calle
el martes Colombia será la sede para la
Cumbre acerca de la situación política
en Venezuela un encuentro que es
impulsado por el presidente Gustavo
Petro quien Busca destrabar los diálogos
entre el gobierno de Nicolás maduro y la
oposición sin embargo no habrá ni
representante desde el ejecutivo ni de
sus contradictores de hecho este lunes
se conoció que el líder opositor
venezolano Juan guaidó viajó a Bogotá
para reunirse con algunas de las
delegaciones internacionales que
participarán en el diálogo a pesar de
que el tribunal supremo de Justicia
venezolano le impidió salir del país
desde enero de 2019 entre tanto Maduro
sostuvo que espera que a raíz de la
conferencia se levanten todas las
sanciones contra Venezuela
una conferencia para
Buscar el levantamiento de todas las
sanciones todas las sanciones sin
condicionamiento de ningún tipo sobre
Venezuela
No aceptamos menos de esa conferencia de
Bogotá el levantamiento de todas las
sanciones para que Venezuela tenga la
libertad comercial la libertad
financiera la libertad económica de su
actividad normal
para poder recuperar todo lo que hay que
recuperar en lo económico en lo
productivo en lo social
para que se acabe el chantaje la
coerción la coacción la agresión
permanente sobre nuestra economía sobre
nuestra vida social el levantamiento de
todas las sanciones sobre Venezuela
todas
aún no le leen los cargos formales al
expresidente peruano Alejandro Toledo
quien fue extraditado desde Estados
Unidos el domingo audiencia de control
de acusación continuará el martes y la
fiscalía lo señala de lavado de activos
Por presuntamente recibir 35 millones de
dólares por parte de odebrecht Mientras
tanto el expresidente seguirá cumpliendo
sus 18 meses de prisión preventiva
una escolta presidencial cortesía de
Interpol el expresidente peruano
Alejandro Toledo regresó el domingo de
California a su país con un comité de
bienvenida muy particular la fiscalía
general de notificó oficialmente su
extradición solicitada desde hace cinco
años entre sus partidarios reunidos en
el aeropuerto se encontraba su hermano
Él se ha puesto a la orden de la
justicia correcto
el todo el proceso en Estados Unidos se
ha cumplido él ha asumido todo lo los
protocolos está acá jefe de estado de
2001 a 2006 Alejandro Toledo está
acusado de embolsarse un soborno de 35
millones de dólares del gigante
brasileño de la construcción odebrecht
para facilitar la construcción de una
nueva autopista pero el expresidente que
se enfrenta una pena de hasta 20 años de
prisión protesta por su inocencia
una dictadura militar es un gobierno
ilegítimo mientras espera su juicio
Toledo se encuentra en prisión
preventiva en la misma prisión que otros
dos expresidentes Alberto fujimori y
Pedro Castillo la destitución de
Castillo a finales de 2022 desencadenó
una grave crisis política en Perú un
país a menudo sacudido por escándalos de
corrupción política desde 1990 seis de
los 11 presidentes de Perú han sido
procesados o condenados por corrupción
Estados Unidos volvió a deportar
migrantes hacia Cuba y lo hizo enviando
a 123 personas en aviones estos vuelos
desde Estados Unidos habían sido
suspendidos en diciembre de 2020 y ahora
el departamento de seguridad Nacional
los reanuda en un contexto en el que se
alcanzó un récord de cubanos que
emigraron al país norteamericano Durante
los últimos meses esto Dijo el
Ministerio del interior de Cuba
efectuada primera devolución de
migrantes irregulares por Estados Unidos
a Cuba vía aérea desde diciembre de 2020
con 40 balceros capturados en costas de
este país y 83 detenidos en la frontera
sur de manera sorpresiva la cadena de
noticias estadounidense Fox news anunció
que terminó su relación laboral con
Tucker carlson quien era considerado
como uno de sus presentadores más
populares y polémicos desde Miami
Anthony corresponsal nuestro tiene más
información
que el calcio en la estrella de la
división de noticias de Fox ha dejado de
formar parte de la compañía la cadena de
televisión a través de un comunicado ha
confirmado que tanto la empresa como el
presentador habían llegado a un acuerdo
para separarse y en ese mismo texto
agradecía los servicios prestados la
destitución del principal conductor de
programas de opinión de Fox se produce
pocos días después de que la cadena
resolviera un caso de difamación al
llegar a un acuerdo con la compañía de
tecnología electoral dominion y se
comprometiera a pagar más de 787
millones de dólares en forma de
compensación para así evitar resolverlo
por la corte de no haber llegado a un
acuerdo un Jurado iba a determinar si
Fox que es uno de los mayores grupos de
comunicación de todo el mundo difamó de
dominion al afirmar en programas como el
de tuckelson que hubo un supuesto fraude
electoral en las elecciones de 2020
cuando Donald Trump perdió la reelección
ante la obra presidente Joe biden de
hecho en el espacio de opinión de uno de
los programas de mayor audiencia de
Estados Unidos varios abogados llegaron
a decir que dominion utilizó algoritmos
para transferir votos del candidato
republicano a Joe biden algo que nunca
se ha podido demostrar que el calzón era
una de las caras más conocidas de Fox
news el presentador de 53 años dirigía
Este programa desde 2016 atrayendo a más
de 334.000 espectadores Entre 25 y 54
años cada noche más del doble que su
principal competidor en cnnen y mbc en
el espacio si han llegado a vertir
polémicas opiniones sobre los migrantes
o la comunidad lgbtq en Estados Unidos
en Brasil hay 1,6 millones de indígenas
casi el doble de lo que apuntaba el
recuento anterior según los datos
preliminares del censo que se realizó en
2022 el crecimiento agrícola amenaza
Cada día los territorios protegidos y
muchos de sus habitantes se ven
obligados a huir hacia las ciudades
nuestros corresponsales Valeria sakone
amiguidara y Fanny lotea nos cuentan la
historia
marai es el nombre de nuestra tierra
sagrada
en guaraní maraíéis significa Tierra sin
mal los indígenas de la aldea mata verde
bonita en el estado de Río de Janeiro
protestan contra la construcción de un
Macro complejo turístico
yo les ordené que parasen están
masacrando a mi pueblo ahora por la
mañana cortaron estos árboles dos tres
Cuántos árboles cortaron aquí 40
familias viven en esta restinga
protegida por Su riqueza medioambiental
estamos en maricá el municipio que
acumula el mayor crecimiento del pib de
Brasil gracias a los royalties del
petróleo
pero esta riqueza no llega a la
población indígena que mal vive en casas
de barro
esta paja está desapareciendo aquí de
nuestra región por eso nuestras casas
Están en malas condiciones
estos guaraníes fueron realojados aquí
hace una década tras ser expulsados de
una región vecina por la especulación
edilicia nunca recibieron los títulos de
propiedad de las tierras no se oponen a
la construcción de un Resort de lujo
pero en contrapartida exigen al
ayuntamiento que invierta en saneamiento
y en salud
guaraní atrapada entre los rascacielos
de San Pablo es el símbolo de la
resistencia de los indígenas ante el
avance de la presión urbanística Aquí
viven 700 personas repartidas en seis
aldeas en su momento fue la región
indígena demarcada más pequeña del país
posee tan solo 1,73 hectáreas ya tuvimos
niños atropellados aquí por causa de la
división que los no indígenas hicieron
en nuestra aldea para poder llegar al
centro de Sao Paulo
estos indígenas urbanos son
discriminados por los blancos de la
ciudad y también por los nativos de las
reservas que los critican por haber
perdido sus tradiciones y su lengua
original
hasta aquí las noticias Gracias por
elegirnos
[Música]